[Music]
welcome wel to wisdom for life where we
sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your everyday life hi I'm Dan Hayes and
I'm joined by my co-host Dr Greg Sadler
and today we're talking about
interesting questions about stoicism so
we mean stoic philosophy and the
worldwide movement that includes
hundreds of thousands of people who are
practicing stoicism and we thought we
would focus on this in part because it's
what we call the season of stoicism once
again which includes the big
International stoicon you know a
convention for people that are
interested in stoics and that's online
again this year there's stoic on X
events all over the world Dan and I have
participated in them quite a bit in the
past and there's stoic week coming up
where you can actually like try out
living like a stoic for a week and what
we did is put out a call in social media
for topics and issues and questions
pertaining to stoicism that people would
like me and Dan to give our takes on as
people who've been studying this for a
long time and thinking about it and
organized you know the Milwaukee stoic
Fellowship which still exists and it's
going on quite well so that's what we're
going to do in this episode we're GNA
kind of you know do a Q&A uh Dan
proposed we could call this a stoicism
AMA but you can't ask us question
questions because we're already
recording
this right um and just so you guys know
if you want to know more about stoon and
uh you go to Modern stoicism
docomo con and that's s i n yeah I mean
it and stoicon is kind of a cool thing
there's like a a mixture of everything
from you know very academically oriented
deep into the text kind of stuff to much
more popularly oriented matters and the
theme this year is stoicism and Beauty
which I think is kind of cool oh the
Aesthetics is sois yeah there you go and
to you know like obviously regularly
there's you know idea of like sism kind
of being at least grouped in with the
the Aesthetics or the Aesthetics I'm
sorry aesthtics Aesthetics um but
they're they're not aesthetic and we can
appreciate Beauty and we can have nice
things and and there's also there's the
beauty and interacting with other people
in in virtuous
ways yeah and you know Marcus
Aurelius he has this really cool passage
where he talks about like looking at the
cracks in bread and the imperfections in
it and finding Beauty in that or in the
lines on people's faces as they age or
even uh no I don't know if everyone
would find this beautiful the um mouths
of fierce beasts like a lion opening it
its mouth up and you know if you have
the right attitude you can find that
instead of terrifying you can find it
beautiful right and it's kind of like
one of the big Ideas within sism is
reframing things from what you might
have thought to something different as
long as you can reframe the way that you
look at it you can have a very different
um reaction to it when it appears to you
I should mention too so we have done
some episodes in the past
on various exercises associated with or
coming out of stoic philosophy and
reframing them is is one of them so if
you're interested in this you can go
into our back catalog and find a lot of
cool stuff discussing philosophical
practices um exercises whatever you want
to call
them right um and they definitely you
know improve my life with uh many of
these practices
also yeah we we call this practice of uh
taking a philosophical idea and actually
putting it into practice um with a very
rigorous uh set of circumstances and um
over time you see think of like
mindfulness meditation and Buddhism
would be a practice of theory and
practice put together yeah so I think
before we jump into the questions just
in case anybody is a bit confused about
what stoicism is we probably have to say
at least a few words about stoicism as a
philosophy of of life um when you think
about it or let yeah let me ask you this
Dan what's your elevator pitch of what
stoicism is I've never had a I've never
put together a good one but maybe you
have um it is a way in looking at the
world in which uh you are not Disturbed
and can find beauty in the
interactions and um everyday occurrences
okay yeah that's that's that's a good
one some people say things like living
in accordance with nature which was a
old slogan of the stoics but boy does
that mean a lot of different things to
different people God that's such an
unpacking that's
like there's another one that's kind of
popular which is um the the idea that
moral virtue is the only true good but I
don't think that's quite right I mean
people do put that forward sometimes but
the stoics didn't think that that was
the only good thing they talk about
friendship for example uh and other good
things but it it's pretty close the idea
that what we ought to be focusing on is
our our character and cultivating
certain important virtues like justice
or Temperance or courage or or wisdom I
mean what else would you say is really
Central to it so
like the the word for virtue in Greek is
arate which is like excellence and so I
always talk about like to be a stoic is
to be an excellent human and so like in
stoicism we're trying to investigate
what is an excellent human and then
trying to comport our lives and our
actions to being excellent yeah without
a road map and that's what the
philosophy is providing us with it's
hard to make much consistent progress
right and thus you know stoicism has a
number of different uh disciplines and
like uh logic is also very important for
us to like okay how can we like if we've
got all these competing ideas of what
the good is how can you actually make an
argument that can stand on its own two
feet to say like okay well this should
be what the good is it's interesting too
I mean before we get into the questions
and we should do that pretty soon
somebody like Epic tus who's a important
stoic teacher he is content to let
people if they say ah I don't like logic
I just want to you know practice things
he's like hey go ahead and try that see
how far that gets you and then as soon
as you start getting confused about
stuff then you can come back to school
because we'll teach you logic here and
so I think there is an element to
stoicism of you have to let people
experiment with it and fail every once
in a while and and then they can um pick
themselves up and see why the classic
formulations of things are set up the
way that they are I there's a story and
I can't remember if it's like in epitus
or um and uh Marcus really is talking
about um a student going to a teacher
and it's like I hate logic um yeah and
he's like okay well um if you can prove
to me that you don't need logic then you
won't have to turn learn
[Laughter]
yeah well I think that is the same
student we have in mind um yeah epic
epicus has a lot of great zingers and
it's you know it's due to his his own
student Aryan who wrote this stuff down
um picking like what what must have been
the best conversations with him you know
yeah out of a selection like if you want
to laugh at at some ancient Stoke
writings then idas is definitely your
guy he's got like constant like things
like oh my
God yeah and he's not like um a standup
or something they're not jokes no it's
just the way that he actually talks to
people and the startling holy crap did
he actually say that yeah uh is is is
often quite funny and and he you know he
jokes about himself as well you know
yeah and and that's the one of the
practices that we talked about earlier
is you know um learning how to laugh at
yourself to say like oh that guy he's
he's calling me like a bum and that uh I
smell bad well he doesn't know me at all
well enough because if that's all he
said then you know he could have said
this and this and this and this those
are the least of my worries right I
don't care about
those well should we should we jump into
taking some of these uh questions yeah
what's the first one there Greg okay so
Harold uh cavy asked what are some of
the big things people tend to get wrong
when they're encountering stoicism for
the first time and I think this is a
great
question so what do you think I guess
the the colloquial word for stoicism in
the English language now is to be like
someone that is uh unemotional that
they've like you know stuffed all their
emotions down to uh you know that
British stiff upper lip and that is just
about the partless from the truth
because it that is ignoring emotions
whereas the ideas with in capital
stoicism is that you are so in tune with
why you are actually having these
feelings in the first place that you can
look at them and not be disturbed by
them when they come about that they are
good sources of information about a
situation but that you should not let
them take the Reign from you you know
and I think there's a broader issue
there stoics would never suggest to you
that if you're confronted with some sort
of reality you should ignore that
reality or distorted into something that
it that it isn't right so when you know
we were talking about reframing
reframing is not like lying to yourself
and making believe that things are great
when they're not great it's finding
finding ways of looking at something
that are actual possible objective ways
of understanding the situation that
you're you're just kind of leaving out
it's it's deliberately shifting Focus
from one interpretation to
another
right what else what what are some other
misconceptions on like sometimes people
think of like a stoic as H Spock if
you're familiar with Star Trek you know
uh Spock is sometimes referred to as a
straw stoic the like the the purely
logical no emotion reacting guy although
you actually watch uh the original
series of Star Trek he he reacts
emotionally a
lot
uh yeah he's he's emot he's very
passionately attached to logic isn't he
oh yeah to the point where it blinds him
a number of times that's that's a
recurring Trope for Spock um but yeah
the idea that that is the ideal of a
stoic is is really incorrect as well as
you know the ancient stoics are
described as happy and jovial um right
and so to to think of someone as like
you know Dow like that would be a really
poor description of what a capitalist
philosophical stoic would be yeah you
know I think one of the things that
people often get wrong as well is
they'll go out and they'll find some
quotes or they'll read a blog entry or
they'll they'll read like a short
secondary literature book and not read
like actual Sena or epicus or Marcus
Aurelius and they'll pick up a few bits
and pieces pie here and there and say
okay I understand stoicism now you know
it's this this proposition and this
proposition when really it's like an
entire network of ideas that were
developed over hundreds of years so
they're going to be complicated and so I
guess we could summarize this by people
think that
stoicism is simpler to express and wrap
your head around than it actually is and
the one other thing I'll add to that
that we've already brought up a little
bit the EXP experiential or practical
element you really if you want to
understand the concepts you really have
to put them into practice and see what
they what they do in your life um it's
one thing to understand them cognitively
it's another thing to integrate them
into the way that you like talk to
people or you know handle your emotions
or just make decisions in life and then
when you do that it's sort of like
climbing up a hill you know you you can
see the top of the hill before you climb
up it and then you climb up the top of
the hill and now you can see a lot
further and maybe you actually see that
well I'm actually at a plateau and this
goes on for miles and now I'm going to
walk on level ground or maybe there's
another Hill that's even bigger that you
couldn't see before and so if you're not
putting in the the time and the work and
like
continually growing you're you're
probably not going to get as much out of
it as somebody who's just like
collecting quotes and then looking at
them on their calendar or you know on
their phone or something like that yeah
that's why there's like um a number of
places I know that like uh mosmo Puchi
and Greg Lopez put out a book on like
stoic
practices I actually have a copy a
handbook for new stoics that's right
yeah and that that's a like a good like
resource to find something and it's like
it's set up like you know 52 weeks and
you can do something for a year if you
want to um or if you want just like go
and pull out those and and practice them
but like the ideas just as we will have
here for the week um right before
stoicon um sorry right after the um
stoic week is stoic week this time is a
little bit separated it's it's in
November okay but St week is a a a time
for new people to actually try to
practice um some of the the stoic
practices in a a at least a regimented
way that know and it's sometimes it's
nice to have a little bit of external
motivation and structure to allow you to
actually do these things and uh see if
they actually produce any benefits for
you yeah should we should we move on to
the next one oh absolutely so this is
from somebody on Twitter and she has a
pretty funny moniker Lydia the swey
stoic and heroic coach and she says how
not to get sucked into the crap show of
the world while still being aware of the
crap show of the the world so you know
she's asking how do you actually do that
and I think it's a great question
because one of the things that it's
actually presupposing is that the world
is kind of a a mess and I mean you could
say that from a classic stoic
perspective you could say well it's all
Harmony it all does make sense but
that's that's not actually what like
epicus or Marcus aelius are telling you
they'll they'll say yeah people are
screwed up man and they make dumb
decisions and Marcus will actually say
not only do they do that in the present
they've been doing that for age after
age after age and they're probably going
to do that long after you're dead so how
do you so I guess the question is like
getting at how do you see the world as
it is which is an imperfect messed up
place without letting that get to you
yeah like you know Marcus really is the
the meditations are a little notebook to
himself like trying to like make sure
that he's doing his practices and and
being able to see the world in a better
way and and one of them that comes to
mind is him like sitting there is like
what are you going to do are you going
to like sit in your bed with your covers
over your head all day um like the bees
are out there putting their world
together all the other animals are
putting their world together as best
they can why are you going to sit here
and not actually do the work of a man do
your stuff um and the other part of this
is um directly to um trying to not let
the the ways of the world or the the the
crab show of the world you'll get you
down is um because the world is an
external and we shouldn't have our um
our well-being our our um equinity be
disturbed by the the State of Affairs of
the external world it's good to try to
make the world better but the the
motivation shouldn't be the the state of
the world at the moment it should be you
know a new source of motivation uh with
a a source from within yourself that
like I I want to be an excellent person
what does an excellent person do the
excellent person doesn't get you know
disturbed because there are some
setbacks uh you do what you can do you
know and allowing yourself to get upset
over things that maybe don't matter as
much or maybe they do matter but they
don't matter to the degree that we we uh
ascribe value to them that gets in the
way of what you're just talking about of
like fulfilling our our roles and our
duties to other people or um thinking
about how to improve our own character
right because it it takes it takes our
it takes us in a different direction and
it it consumes our time and
attention um and I you know I I think
that um you know a stoic doesn't have to
say hey everything's cool I'm great with
this they can they can actually say like
oh this this thing that's happening over
here is really evil or unjust or
terrible um they don't have to expect
that everybody else views the world in a
stoic way but the trick is um how do you
how do you take on that
realization but remove the sting you
could say
right I've I've written this about this
a little bit in the past um and I call
it like the sto trap oh let's hear about
that and so the idea here is that like
you know within stoicism it's like okay
these things are externals and but then
like almost everything is an external
and so if everything's an external and
doesn't actually have value in of itself
then people like oh well you know you
know that that bad thing is happening
doesn't matter it's it's external U and
then you can get to this place where you
kind of really istic nothing matters and
um and thus you have no motivation to do
anything and know you have to change
because you know usually before you kind
of like take the stok mindset the um the
external world and that the things that
are happening to them are the things
that matter the most um and so if things
are bad there then you know things are
bad whereas in a St mind view it's I I
can try to be the best person I can be
um and that's my new motivation to try
to now make that put the world in order
as best I can yeah at least a little bit
of it that we have some not necessarily
control over but say involvement or
influence over right yeah so Kyle
Cunningham has a question um is there a
clash between stoic Concepts and the
modern world that mean we need to adjust
our soak ideas for example social media
and how to manage it what do you think
about uh stoicism and social media I
mean I think that stoicism has plenty to
tell us about social media I don't think
that social
media by its sheer existence you know
now um and not having existed back in
the time of the classic stoics means
that like we have to change stoicism
because we've encounter this new thing I
think you just take a look at you know
what people like senica or epicus have
to say about um our interactions with
other people and you adapt it to social
media right I mean if you think about it
social media is really quite new it
didn't exist when I was a kid um it's
you know what 20 years old perhaps I
mean maybe we could say it's a little
bit older if we want to think about
websites that no longer exist or we want
to count um bbs's as social media what
do you I mean you you know more about
the tech stuff than I do would you say a
BBS is is social media or not uh sure uh
because you interact with people right
yeah um I know this reminds me of of
senica talking about either going um to
the games or going to the bath house
that you're okay you're shouldn't be
worried if you get jostled and are
overhear things that you might not like
to hear if you're going to go to public
place and be with other public people
these are yeah these are the things you
know they talk about um reframing it and
think of it as a festival like know uh
in instead of like this um this negative
thing you might have to interact with
and interacted with all these people
it's like oh just reframe it as a
festival and now it's like oh well in a
festival you know you have to interact
with people but they're all doing
something like positive and and there's
a you know a uh Road uh to to progress
down and and you can uh change your
reactions to that I I was kind of
thinking of a passage from epicus where
he talks about news and he says strictly
speaking news isn't good or bad um it
just you know the events that are being
narrated are what they are and then it's
what we invest them with that makes them
good or bad to us and one thing that
social media does is it um it makes
us kind of curious about well what are
other people saying what do they think
think about stuff and you know we don't
have to care actually um we can log in
and do our little thing and say oh
that's interesting that people say these
things and then get out I mean you could
say that um maybe we should avoid uh
Wars with people on social media but we
could say the same thing about shouting
at your neighbor across the hall you
could do that just as easily in in real
life right or yelling at people on the
street uh you don't need social media
necessarily to be a jerk right and so
like this this already fits in pretty
well like okay what what does social
media like do that's kind of like new um
is that it kind of hijacks our yeah uh
the fact that we are social creatures
and that we desire approval from our
peers but the problem is that you know
our peer group used to be like I don't
know 200 people at most and and now it's
you know tens of thousands and all of a
sudden um
you your your brain isn't uh hasn't
developed in a way that should be able
to take in the uh negative or positive
feedback of tens of thousands of people
um it's just not how we developed as a
species and um but if you take some so
Concepts that you know your reputation
isn't a good or a bad isn't external it
is not up to you then uh you once you
can like try to uh diffuse that
situation at its very beginning I'm
laughing because um one of the goals of
a lot of people in social media is to
have a viral post a post that people
will look at respond to and then repost
and it will gain a lot of traction right
and there's something like success
leading to success with these and I have
had a few viral posts in my life mostly
on Twitter and the one that I had most
recently it was the dumbest thing you
know um you know and I I've like posted
I don't
know tens of thousands of tweets at this
point because I've been on Twitter since
I I like 2008 or 2009 and it was just me
responding to somebody else who' said
something about Hegel videos and I
retweeted it and said I've shot a few of
them or I've done a few of them myself
and then somehow people like glommed on
to that and they're like yeah he has you
know and not a lot of people had
anything to say about it they just kept
like reposting it and I was like of all
the dumb things you know I mean I've
said things that are interesting maybe
even a little profound from time to time
why didn't any of those go viral why did
this stupid remark go go viral and then
I thought to myself well at least it's
not anything bad like I'm not going
viral because I went into an exploitive
lace rant out in front of quick trip or
something like that and somebody was
filming so yeah but I think you're right
that social media it doesn't radically
change the game but if it faces us with
new
problems um one of which is like you
said it does hijack our our uh our
systems and so what would a stoic say
well you know that so be on guard
against it right I mean don't be a dummy
if you know that if you're walking
through like uh you're like Indiana
Jones and you're in the I forget which
temp is it the Temple of Doom where it's
all the snakes or is that Raiders of the
Lost Arc um oh there's there's there's
snakes and M several of them cuz he
doesn't like snakes so if you know
you're going to walk down a hallway full
of snakes I don't know shine your
flashlight or try to avoid stepping on
him right I mean it's not rocket science
as we say right
um and the one other thing we didn't
quite hit on here was that um uh
Concepts in the modern world yes we we
know more that's great like the Stokes
are you know we regularly talk about
understanding things that we have
Impressions the world we see things with
our um experiences and our senses and we
take them in and we try to make a really
good understanding of it they talk about
like what is understanding and knowledge
with this open hand closed hand and hand
over fist um and as we know more about
the world we have a better refinement of
like you know physics or how you know
biological systems work how social
systems work and with that we have
better understanding of the world and we
can make better um
uh decisions about how we should react
to these things because we know more I
guess like uh senica has a really bad
take on uh earthquakes um from way back
when we only learned about play tonics
uh like about a hundred years ago and so
yeah we we have a new thing it updates
our model of the world and now we can
make better decisions about how to be
excellent in that world now knowing new
stuff well you know this is a good segue
into um
another one that got asked um by Jackie
friend how about discussing the concept
of a conscious and providential universe
what this means or how this applies to
us as stoics this is a reference to
ancient stoicism because they actually
did believe that sort of stuff um what
do you I mean does the science support
anything like that in your
view not that I've
seen um if it is it's outside the um
world of observation okay yeah so it
would be sort of like a faith commitment
then rather
than I kind of see him yeah and this is
actually like an ongoing conversation
between you know modern socialism and
the traditional stoks and like you know
more power to them um I'm I'm not a
traditional stoic um and I also will
happily like incorporate other ideas
from other schools of thought if they
seem to be good um but yeah this uh this
idea that you know yes we all have a uh
piece of the the Divine or the the um
Universal logos um that is uh Puma or
Numa um that um is the animating portion
of us and that is the the source of our
reason as humans um is a
very cohesive story it's internally
consistent um but it it doesn't seem to
as far as I can see hold up to the
observational
scrutiny yeah and you know it's
interesting because um Marcus Aurelius
at a number of points in his meditations
will say um the universe could be
arranged the way that stoics think so
it's it's providential there's some sort
of like plan to things and it's for the
best and it's uh rational or it could be
epicurian atams which means just random
stuff like sort of like what we tend to
think about today right uh following
physical laws that you know produce this
really cool universe that we're in but
there's no like overarching intelligence
running it and Marcus says it could be
either one of these but that doesn't
mean a thing as far as like me actually
living my life as a good person even if
it is just random stuff I I'm not
disabled from uh behaving like a
virtuous
person and I I think that's really great
you know because clearly he does think
that there's there's a providential
ordering but he's willing to say yeah I
mean even if there isn't um that's not
the point I it's sort of like these
people um and I'm not saying that this
is an exact analogy so I don't want
people to get me wrong but there are
people out there who like oh if you take
God out of the equation then there can't
be any morality and you're like wow I
don't want to walk down a dark alley
with you if that's really what you think
because so if if you don't believe in
God now you like you know lie cheat
steal murder rape um I mean maybe you
could just be a good person right yeah
um personally uh I do uh all the raping
and murdering I want none yeah go like I
don't have a desire to do that I don't
have to have something else tell me it's
bad to not want to do
that yeah well I mean what they're
confessing is that they actually would
do it they want to do it and all that's
holding them back is some scary guy in
the sky who will Smite them if they if
they indulge their appetites I mean yeah
I'd want I don't care what a person
actually is committed to in terms of
their cosmology if I can count on them
not to do bad stuff that's really great
you know and and I I think that was a
hon quote so oh was it I think so but
I'm not sure but I want to give credit
where credit is due
um uh what do you want to which one do
you want to uh tackle next yeah
um I one that I actually think is quite
interesting and I'd be really curious to
get your take on this because it's it's
a little bit cynical uh it's from Andy
do you think that the idea of focus on
all the segmented applications of
stoicism to roles we occupy and
professions we choose are necessary it
often feels a bit like over marketing a
quick way of selling books offering life
hacks advertising conference tickets or
gaining followers than something that
adds any actual value and I will say
there is a lot of stuff out there where
it's like the stoic XYZ right and you
read the stuff and you're like this
person doesn't understand stoicism at
all they've just like gleaned a few
quotes some of which are actually F fake
quotes and they're putting them in there
and then they're like the stoic lawyer
or the stoic politician or I don't know
the sto stoic uh manicurist or something
like that I I I think that um that's a
legitimate
complaint and um I think there you know
as with any popular thing there's people
who jump in basically to grift and make
some money and and try to get some uh
Prestige out of it some some juice for
themselves but those are all externals
right so these are people who are Mal
adapting stoicism in a way that shows
they don't understand it because they're
basically taking a a great philosophy
and trying to turn it into a driver for
their worldly success usually without
much success either you
know I I find the like you know the
marketers are going to Market and the
business majors are going to business
and and they find they find a niche that
feels like that's going to work for them
and make some money they're gonna do it
uh okay I might not agree with it but
like you know
um I guess it's sometimes annoying if it
gets a things duded and it gets people
set on the wrong path um yeah there's um
there and and I'm not going to like uh
disparage all of them there's going to
be some good people that are going to be
there they might not be the most
scholarly but they can maybe uh bring
people into like oh this might be an
interesting philosophy that I want to
get more into
um I don't know like it once again it's
it's a little bit of an external and
like they're going to do their thing um
I guess uh if I feel so uh outraged
about it then I guess I could put out my
own book that's like try to be better
and and uh hopefully it catches on um
but I'm not be like what you're
articulating is actually a good stoic
perspective on that I I don't control
other people's you know desires and
plans and stuff like that or marketing
campaigns that's that's their business
and you know if they're doing something
wrong like misrepresenting what stoicism
is about or making making claims like oh
you just do these 10 steps and like your
life is going to be
amazing um you know it's probably enough
for me to say well that's not quite true
I don't have to like go and burn up
every copy of their books you right and
which would be kind of irrational right
and if if they're going to say you do
these things in your life is going to be
amazing like from what perspective like
if you say like oh you're going to get
wealth privilege like that that'd be
like antithetical to the ideas and sisms
like it's you trying to be a good person
and also being um you know happy you
know to uh love fate to a more day of uh
the the world that you live in and
sometimes it's going to suck and
sometimes it's going to be great and you
should love both of those things because
you are in this world and you're
experiencing it yeah that's that's a
good perspective on it
um which which one should we take on
next um let's do Kathy oconnell okay um
I like you if you haven't already to
discuss women and sism and how our
practice of sism differs in light of our
lives and
biologies so that's an interesting one
in in stoicism today which is like the
online blog of the modern uh stoicism
organization there was actually and
we'll put links to this below
um there was a online seminar that
brought in a whole bunch of women to
talk about stoicism what they thought
stoicism you know had in terms of
prospects for women whether it needed to
be updated in certain ways and um it was
quite good H there were a lot of
different
perspectives and I I think that's a
great
resource um I mean you um talk about
like one or two of them that you thought
were particularly interesting
yeah I mean there there is there is some
misogyny in classic stoicism because
it's part of the culture right right so
senica will say things like a person who
is failing morally is effeminate right
and we can easily say ah okay he's he's
mixing some things up we don't have to
use that language anymore or in the
older translations quite often um the
Latin term homo which is gender Neal or
the Greek term anthropos which is also
gender neutral is always translated as
man right um and we can say person
instead of that and I I think that's
that's a great strategy we we we want
you know we should want to be inclusive
and not say well stoicism is just for
the dudes man you know it's not really
for for women um and then um Andy who
asked one of these questions earlier
said I am um you know I I think that
stoicism is great for women because
women are people it's not great for
women just because they're women it's
because we're all human beings and now
Katherine is asking uh um about like in
light of our lives and biologies and and
we can say that you know there are
differences in biology um they're not
like absolutely determinative it's not
like there's women brains and and you
know Ma men's Brains or anything like
that the way that some people like to
pretend
with pseudo science um and you know um
lives do vary because culture varies but
I I think you know a contemporary stoic
would want to be
egalitarian and say this needs to be
something that can be equally valuable
for men and for women yeah what's what's
your view uh like it comes back to um I
don't know I guess masonius ruus which
we only have a few things about it but
talks about like this specifically and
should women be taught philosophy and uh
he's like yeah they have the the
capacity to reason like just like every
other person has a capacity to reason
and if you um you uh nurture that then
it can flourish just like any other
person and with cism we see our capacity
for reason as like our most important
feature as a human um so yeah like in
that case that is our most important
feature there might be you know people
that are stronger or weaker in
in any number of different like talents
and if they want to do those things that
they are talented at good do those
things um but our ability to reason is
is not something that is you know uh
reserve for only one of the sex and um
and they obviously like there's a number
of people that are at least referred to
as potential stoics that are women in
the ancient world but we have almost no
writing or um you know about from them
and um little writing about them but
there's a a whole bunch of really you
know interesting uh modern women that
are talking about and working St system
and if you're going to like look for um
people to read or to actually be
interested about I would go with them
like there's know a number of them you
know Karen Duffy shanell Nancy shriman
uh there's a lot of them that are out
there in the space that are looking for
uh are are are seeking the stoic path in
a a much better way and I guess I'd say
yeah um with translations a lot of them
especially the ones that are publicly
available um like you know out of
copyright are you know these kind of
older things and S will often refer to
things as womenly I think epitus also
does that yeah um and we can we can use
better words that are actually closer to
the description of what they actually
mean in or in without having to bring
the gender directly into it yeah and
sometimes we have to say they're just
wrong like epicus will say that a man
ought to have a beard and if he doesn't
have a beard he's not really a man you
know U and you you look at that and
you're like well I mean what about guys
who can't grow a beard or you know what
about cultures where I mean really I
mean until the 1970s and it was kind of
a subculture thing then yeah if you were
a guy you were clean shaven unless you
were some you know weird Egghead or
something like that right you also wee a
hat all the time too does that mean we
have to wear hats constantly
you know I think some of this is is
culturally driven and we just have to
like put it aside you know and that's
one of these other things is like you
know um sism isn't a Dogma you don't
have to follow exactly what they are
this is a conversation over centuries
and we can update it because we have as
we were just talking about new
information about the world we have a
better understanding of the world and
thus we can make better um uh models and
decisions based on those models yeah
here's a question and and it's one that
I we have a list and this is kind of far
down on the list but I think we actually
should talk about this one this is from
Toby Kelce should stoics prze or just
lead by example what what do you think
about that one like this has gone back
and forth and
um I don't know I I am torn like there's
nothing in the like the the will talk
about like hey don't tell people about
this stuff um you know show it like you
know does the um the Sheep uh show its
crud in its mouth to the the shepherd or
does it show it by having growing a a
nice
fleece um and so also like people that
are prizing are usually really annoying
and they're also often like the people
that are new to it it's like oh my God I
found this thing and it's amazing and I
want to share it with you and like I
guess on you know I I was at least a
little bit guilty about that at some
point in my life um I've uh tamped that
down but I I think uh maybe an idea like
we they had these stoked schools in the
past and like it's not exactly prosing
but there was a a place for people to
gather and actually talk about these
things and potentially even learn about
it in a more you know regimented way so
that's it I think it's a false dichotomy
because you've got on the one hand just
like keeping it to yourself leading by
example showing people that you're
you're actually following the uh the
program let's say right and then you've
got way over here on the other end prati
or evangelizing and then I think in the
middle you do actually have like
teaching to people that want to be
taught or offering informational
workshops where you're not pushing it
but saying well here's an idea that you
can consider or um you know a friend
comes to you and they're like oh I got
this problem and you're like well here's
uh some ideas that could actually help
you out and maybe you don't even tell
them it's it's stoicism you just say
some things are in your control other
things are not and if you mix those up
you're going to be unhappy you don't
have to say well this is epicus and
cidian one or something like that right
um so if they're like you know big into
Christianity that you can like give them
the Serenity Prayer that's you know like
that's a course do idea just it's also
been adopted by another you know
philosophy and
religion yeah and and I think you're
right that prati is a bit
obnoxious um and and so it could be
good-hearted like you were talking about
you find this thing that's really
working for you and you do want to share
it with other people right I mean that's
the original sense of evangelism it
means good news and you want to share
this good news with other people that
you can unscrew up your life in this
case not that you know the Messiah is
coming or something like that but you
you know you've got this thing that'll
work for you and then I think there's a
lot of people who prze because um that's
the way they think that people ought to
behave that you know you want everyone
to be on your team and that's much more
obnoxious right you can you can be like
okay buddy you got this thing and it's
working for you that's nice that's not
too bad right um but the oh we all have
to be doing the same thing cuz I'm doing
this thing now that's I don't know
that's really offputting yeah and it's
that stok because you know doing that is
trying to force something that is not
entirely in your control I like you have
to do this right right it's like here
here here it is and I guess
um oh man I'm I'm I believe it's um epas
talking about like hey um you see
someone make an uh uh a wrong choice um
go and um tell them that they' made a
wrong choice but um you leave it that
like you know you you can you can help
them to know it you can teach them but
you can't force them to do it yeah and
um I think there you know the leading by
example there is something to the like
providing a consistent example that is
important if you see somebody who's
preaching stoicism but then they like
blow up and yell at people um who are
vulnerable to them okay they're not
being a very good stoic then right you
know
like if you go to stoicon and the person
in charge of it is all stressed out and
things aren't working out right and this
has happened at stoicon right um what
what is their demeanor like are they
like well we got problems here but the
world is imperfect and I think we can
handle this and maybe we have to switch
stuff around or are they like knocking
chairs over and they're like ah I can't
believe it it's all gone to crap you
know um one's stoic the other one isn't
right right right
um so uh let see what is another good
question here I think um Toby Kelsey has
one that I really want to talk about
which was how can the soaks approach to
fairness responsibility and Community
inform or improve local communities and
modern politics that is a good one
right we we live in Frau times
right um and um you know tribalism is is
kind of at a a peak and you at least the
stoic answer to this is this idea of
osis and this is you know to expand one
Circle um and um we uh think of uh first
ourselves and then our close family and
then um are are close extended family
and friends and and you you put them on
these tears that are you know smaller
and smaller and the closer they are to
you the um the they uh you'll do more
and more for them um and then we have
these out groups and um like those are
the others and if you get into this kind
of really INR outgroup mentality and
it's like well I want good things to
happen for me and I want bad things to
happen to the outg group and so you go
back to like even Socrates I think it's
all the Republic he's talking with uh
Pol Marcus says um Justice is doing good
to your friends and doing evil to your
enemies right and and and he he
summarily dismisses this by because like
well if the good is always the good then
um for your enemies if they hold the
same idea then the good is to them and
the bad is to their enemies who are you
and so if it's good for uh us to have
good things and also uh good for us to
have bad things be depending on the
point of view you got aad you have a
contradiction so it can't be true um
and so the idea within stoicism they
came up with this this word it's called
cosmopolitanism and that means to be a
uh a person in the polus of the cosmos
or to be a member of uh the the
everything to instead of having these
ingroups and outgroups have at the very
least a group that you say everyone's in
um that there shouldn't be these
outgroups and there might be you know
differences and bickering between
subgroups but we are all part of a
single group and if we can pull together
there and never see anyone as an enemy
um then that will allow us to uh you
know at least deal with people
especially if we're talking about in any
sort of democratic
institution yeah and especially in terms
of local communities I mean one of the
things that you do find when you get
involved with whether it's like um a
political group or a neighborhood or
pick whatever you want there's always
going to be people that you're like well
they're not doing this right you know
they they're in it for the wrong reasons
they just want to like control people or
they're you know they think too much of
themselves or stuff like that well
that's human that's human beings right
we're imperfect and you don't have to
like um excuse it or say well I should
be like that too instead you can say all
right how can I work with these people
and not getting pissed off at them that
might actually be quite helpful or not
denigrating them because you know
they're not behaving in a stoic way um
stoicism can actually make you more
pragmatic in in getting things done and
this is what we see Marcus telling
himself you know tell yourself every
morning when I get up I'm going to deal
with ingrates I'm going to deal with
jerks I'm going to deal with all these
kind of people but they're that way
because they they're mixed up about
things and I'm not and so so I have to
behave in a different way than than they
do and I I think that's a great reminder
so that could be know what the source of
the actual good is exactly yeah yeah
um uh and then I just want to like
expand on osis um this is like it means
like a translation direct translation is
um appropriation and that means in this
case is to appropriate the um the
concerns um and the needs of others into
yourself more and more like it doesn't
have to be like you're one uh entire
like oh now I had to just do everything
for everyone else but like to like at
least acknowledge that there are needs
of other people and that your actions
will influence and react to them and if
you uh don't have any of their um needs
into your like what you're thinking
about and the decisions that you're
making then you will easily make
decisions that will harm them you know I
was just thinking that the stoic virtues
come in here as well and you were
talking about like balancing people's
needs right and that is there's two
there's two virtues that are really
concerned with that one is Justice which
means like you know giving people what
they deserve um and oftentimes we we
think they deserve less than than they
do so maybe we have to like get clear
about what people actually do deserve
and then we don't always have infinite
resources actually we never have
infinite resources
we don't always have enough resources to
give everybody what um we'd like to give
them so we have to figure out like okay
where where are the bus routes going to
run right um who is going to be served
by this initiative and then wisdom is is
part of this practical wisdom and so
stoicism says we need to cultivate these
and I think courage is also needed too
it's it's difficult to stand up against
pressure and have people tell you that
you're you know not only wrong but a
jerk for taking a political stance that
that you have and and you probably need
courage to be able to stick to your guns
you
know yeah that courage you know it's
like it it's great to have an idea of
what is the good but if you can't
actually get up and do the good then
what's the point like hooray I I have
the idea I have the precognition of what
I ought to do if you don't do it then
you won't
yeah courage has to do with like
persevering when things get tough or
facing your fears or um doing the stuff
that's boring that you you know you have
to file all this paperwork but actually
doing
it yeah
so well we might have time for one more
um which one would you like to go out on
you think
um I guess we'll do uh John dwire here
okay when if ever do stoes fight
back I mean we have a great example in
ko ko the the the younger who fought
against Julius Caesar with a guy who he
didn't particularly like uh G Pompei
right he joined as a stoic to protect
the Republic against uh what he viewed
as uh Caesars trying to probably right
Le so to take power for himself and to
subvert the the order of things um and
he fought in a civil war so I mean
there's a guy right off the bat who we
could say fought back not only fought
but like LED like he true yeah you know
mustered a an army to uh try to take out
the forces of of Caesar and the
triumphant uh well not um I I wonder if
if what he means is when should you
fight back if somebody is like
um being mean to you as oppos as opposed
to other people that like you know if if
somebody's bullying your family
members you as a stoic you should you
should stick up for them right but
should you stick up for yourself as a
stoic and this kindes down to that that
idea of like the stoic trap earlier it's
like oh someone's someone's being a jerk
to you um well that's an external okay
there so what and and uh there's a kind
of like this idea of like you know what
is it to be an excellent human is one
thing and then is do you have any
obligations as you know a member of your
family or a m of the community and so
like what what is the the proper way to
react to these things and sometimes the
proper way to react um is to uh call the
authorities or something if that's
that's where it's at right um if you
happen to be an authority that is your
job it is now um your responsibility to
respond or fight back in those
situations in which you have been
designated as the person to do that for
that Community um and so the the
question is
like mostly if you are going to respond
or fight back um do it with virtue can
you do it with temper yeah yeah yeah to
if you're going to have to fight back
you should only use the amount of force
that is necessary to solve the issue and
not to continue to beat the S out of
that person um because it's not going to
that that's being
untempered you know sen has that whole
book on anger right and one of the
things that he does consider in there is
um do we need anger as like a fuel in
order to get the things done that we
need to do like defend people that are
counting on us and his his answer is I
mean you can do that but you're really
playing with fire and it's not a great
way to go about things because your
anger might run out it'll lead you to do
to going too far it's better to to use
reason and and the stoics think that we
can do the right thing motivated by
practical reason and we don't need
negative emotions to get us to to do
that and I think that's that's really
quite different it's a it's a foreign
idea for a lot of people right right um
yeah but uh at this point we got to uh
end the uh conversation here and we're
going to leave you with the words of
senica we so are not subjects of a
despot each of us lays claim to his own
[Music]
freedom